bien alors pascal sevran pour vous
changer les idées ouais on va vous faire
une interview cauchemar
savons pas les foules
il j'ai parlé
et parlé par un bon nous recommençons
l'accès par les
banques s'était tu as raison mais je
suis comme ça mais je n'ose pas des
foires fêtes on ne fait pas du savoir et
qui gérait environ fait don à leur faire
serge on est obligés de leur faire il a
il a parlé on rallume
attention
on ne bouge pas pendant le camp nou pour
le bouchon ne bouge pas pendant le
seigneur
en bouche pendant les diggers voilà
ces maisons c'est plus propre
bien alors voilà donc la fin du
cauchemar le pire truc hein le pire des
accidents conjugaux c'est de vous faire
surprendre par votre amant avec un autre
de surprendre votre amant avec votre
meilleure amie sinon le le pire
cauchemar c'est de trouver la personne
que l'on aime entre andry ravec
quelqu'un d'autre un train de coucher
ouais bon c'est pas très bonnes réponses
[Applaudissements]
et vous djamel
donc que vous arriver de pire c'est de
vous faire surprendre par votre amant
avec un autre vous de surprendre votre
amant avec votre meilleure amie
ne marche pas avec vous le pire cadeau
qu'on puisse vous faire une perceuse
sans fil des vacances avec vanessa
paradis ou l'intégrale de y'a pas photo
en vidéo
l'intégrale de y'a pas photo
ça va loin
la pire situation dans laquelle vous
pourriez vous trouvez pascal sevran
avoir une cigarette mais pas de feu une
carte bleue mais pas de code un mec
sublime mais pas de préservatif
je me doutais bien qu'avec vous
c'est le service public en même temps je
me dis ah oui c'est ça c'est le service
public du gard est et pas de feu ouais
c'est une version à vous pour gens c'est
ça que j'aurais dit un pétard mais pas
trop
non lui c'est pas il les avale les
joindre
la pire des illusions ça serait
d'apprendre qu'il ya quelqu'un dans
casimir
que thierry la fronde a mis une
chaussette dans son collant
ou que chirac est mêlé à la sphère des
hlm de paris que thierry la fronde amis
l'écart est
le pire c'est un portable qui sonne tout
le temps qu'ils savent jamais pensé un
portrait puissant tout le temps ah ouais
vous snc a besoin qu'on vous appelle
toute la journée cette maladie terrible
touche ça comme leur sexe quand
son coucher il met plein la bouche ils
parlent à leurs chiens ils sont tout le
temps face et un terrible et outils
signes extérieurs de détresse ah bravo
le pire c'est grandir seul vivre seul ou
vieillir seul vieillir seul à
le pire c'est de ne plus pouvoir toucher
la personne avec qui vous vivez ou de
plus vouloir la toucher a de plus
pouvoir
le problème de la musique c'est bien
mais quasiment moirés satins l'émission
qui te met devant la réalité de la vie
on a le
pire quand on est plaqué le pire c'est
de l'apprendre par une lettre un coup de
fil ou par quelqu'un reçoit m'est arrivé
quelquefois mais je savais avant donc
que j'aurais on ne m'apprend rien
généralement dans ce domaine le pire
c'est d'apprendre que dieu n'existe pas
ou qu'il existe mais que ce n'est pas le
vôtre
qu'il existe et que c'est pas le mien
djamel
rien rater le il a l'habitude abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu